I think what I'm good at is hiding the
things that I'm not good at like I can't
dance I can't fix anything
you know people meet you guys so oh yeah
Chris de Stefano oh yeah he's ripped
he's he dances like John Travolta he
built a house and none of that stuff is
true welcome to stupid questions
I'm your temporary host Roy Wood jr.
sitting in for Christmas Stefano we're
here to celebrate stand-up monk the
premiere of his our special size 38
waist is tonight we're doing stupid
questions yeah baby so start anyways
make no mistake I have bitch hips what
would be your comedy prom I'd like to
take bill burr I'm a bill burr fan it's
a good hang it's funny he'll probably
get drunk and punched me in the face
because he likes Boston teams and I like
New York teams he'll be in charge which
is the way I like it I like to be
dominated by a man I would love to have
Bill burr read the eulogy at my funeral
Wow
I Love You Man but I'm kind of hoping
you die now you know what the good news
is about your funeral I already got two
tugs what was the hardest thing to
figure out for you special
what show I wanted my parents to come to
I did a 7:30 and 9:30 and I just get
uncomfortable my mom and dad are there
even though I love you guys it's just
kind of hard to talk about my sexual
escapades and the fact that my dad was
in and out of prison my whole life when
my dad is looking at me from the balcony
so I picked her earlier show because I
figured you know the late show will be
as the kids say lit what does your mom
think of the special my mom thinks the
jokes are funny but thinks I curse too
much she's like I just don't understand
you have those beautiful teeth and
they're so white and straight and you
never even had braces my son never had
braces I swear to God but he's got a
filthy mouth
he's got filthy words that come out of
that was a beautiful mouth and those
beautiful teeth and I just wish he
wouldn't that's exactly my mother would
say if you were to start a cult okay
what kind of color I'm not big into
nature so I'm not gonna have one of
these in the woods cults because I'm
scared of animals and wildlife to serve
that so we're gonna have a call to
probably in you know my mother's
basement in Brooklyn and we'll just eat
a lot of pizza and we'll eat a lot of
chocolate
will somehow connect sexually maybe
we'll have a Nutella pizza orgy and then
turn on the water and they'll lecture
ourselves in the bathtub so a stupid
gift time I got you a stupid gift oh
thank you because that's the tradition
of stupid question I've never received
the stupid disposition gift so I can
unwrap a gift for me to you for you
coming on your Wow and look at that it's
no brand chocolate hazelnut spread that
you best believe I'm gonna be putting on
my balls tonight okay get your finger in
there get a sip of that I mean you're
serious about your hazelnut I'm serious
about having to start story a waste kid
I'm serious okay and when I have my
second Comedy Central special it's gonna
be such boys
you